yeah we're inside to Mike Tyson podcast
what's your point
No Deal GG taking over this [ __ ]
leaning maintaining banging their swing
you understand what I'm saying
break it on water cuz we stand real
purified wet bishop magic one he's not
yeah bishop magic water showed up Mike
I'm a cowgirl I'm you have to get him on
the set hey everybody welcome to another
episode of hot boxing with Mike Tyson
I'm Evan Britain with my man Mike Tyson
Mike we've got an unbeliever [ __ ] man
in here today
waddle in here we've got a demigod in
here man Snoop Dogg thanks brother
The Godfather Matt thank y'all famiiy
man you know when a champ called the dog
will answer believe that I'm very
grateful for that race man you know our
relationship is Mike I love you like I
love you let em talk about ain't no
explanation to it well [ __ ] man you guys
have known each other a long time
yeah tell me a little bit about that
once you guys mean well yell with this
alright so listen I came home from
prison in 95 had to been 95 right the
champ came home and you know his
homecoming was was our homecoming we was
happy to see him and put our arms around
him and you know put the whole love
thing around him and then we started
hanging out and started seeing each
other started being a part of each
other's lives and built a brotherhood
you know I'm saying and that's what it's
all about to support each other like
when Mike was the champ he was our champ
and when Mike stop box and he still
remained a champ cuz he was the people's
champ Shane I thought we held him up hmm
that's so awesome man
I mean it's so true about Mike I love
this guy thank you but I love you as
well thank you man and he was never too
big like that's what we loved about him
that he was never too big he always seen
us I die and you know when you at the
pinnacle of your career sometimes you
tend to look down on people but he never
looked down unless he always looked at
us I died it was a mutual respect and
that's the respect that we always have
for him and that's why we love his
business endeavors that he's doing now
we support him and we we happy to see
him doing different things and you know
expanding his
Brannen taking that Tyson thing to
another level because he was the
greatest of all time next to mama dolly
please thank you I met Mike about a year
ago and I couldn't believe the humility
and how humble and I think your heart is
man seriously dude I'm not [ __ ] dude I
know buddy I played six years in the NFL
man I'm just another dude from from
[ __ ] Valley and I had beat Mike and
the dude greets me with a hug
I've been beaten into submission it's
amazing that is great Mike you passed me
that lighter real quick oh thank you
double up now let's see what you wish
[Laughter]
this is a special episode for us come on
now and it's actually gonna be
air-conditioned in here cuz it's a
little toasty
well you said you was hot boxing enjoy
the smoke Mikey you see the round ain't
opiates
the round is not over chair well today
this episode is going to be brought to
you by yeah well if you want a drink
give me some rock dog chicken wine some
rice and great I post from post mates
right yeah hell yeah
ultimate sit-down with each other okay
well post my son Iggy I'm gonna make a
order right now go to Roscoe's give me
five wings some macaroni and cheese rice
and gravy
cornbread and a sunset drink or and put
a lot of icing and little ice cubes
get it together a new opportunity to
meet him man Nipsey Hussle man that bad
that's my dear brother right there
Nipsey is a he's a South Central legend
he was a businessman he was a he was a
leader a teacher a father entrepreneur
all of the above and then the fact that
he was an ex-gang member you know you
know he comes from a gang environment
but he rose and then he built in his
community he bought property in his
neighborhood he
she owned a piece of his neighborhood so
he did things that a lot of ghetto
superstars dream up being from the
neighborhood being loved by the
neighborhood building in the
neighborhood and employing the
neighborhood so he did all of the above
and he was a young man that just really
had vision out of this world so his
legacy definitely will live on
you know it's tragic that his death came
as such an untimely you know time in
this world but we understand that when
God calls on you it's this time you know
I met him before his name yeah
love these receive Wow frightening it
was just it's like a god right yeah i'ma
say it it's like the guy might because
we must know that we do walk amongst
guys and we walk amongst angels and we
need to know that and we just found it
that he was a descendant of alia
Selassie I I was telling somebody else
telling I my friend he looks like him
that's he's a first descendant of him
well he looks like I'm those guys each
yeah yeah retching he is right yes as
far as nationality is tell us about him
do peein if that's already Fallon's
bloodline oh wow King from the king of
all Kings Wow
the Triple Crown walk with lions yeah
believe that gave Queen Elizabeth the
lion sent her one back in the days the
only one with the Triple Crown
Ilia Silesia jah rastafari
i soul if she smoked a lot oh yeah yes
we called the marathon right so I that's
awesome I used to call him all the time
cuz he used to bring me over sex and I
member the last message I sent him he
didn't have enough on me so I was like
don't have me pull up on you cuz I need
some more that marathon and ran out of
my legs and I need some more marathon to
get me to the next level
cuz this weed was so good and it was
called the marathon that was his whole
push was the marathon everything he was
supportive of was the marathon so it was
like the marathon continues and when you
smoking with him it's like you smoking
in a marathon cuz it goes on and
you know life is a marathon Billy is yes
fight pace yourself not a quick fight
yeah pace yourself
shout out your Nipsey Hussle rest in
peace the marathon continues yeah love I
mean [ __ ] dude
Snoop I'm here man I mean I'm here for
y'all I like to talk about the Tyson
ranch that I just seen you know my
cubetto you put that under development
for a little bit of time and I yeah wait
for the water see then in 2020 I believe
Wow
and it's gonna be too mean to be um
high-tech state-of-the-art you know I
mean in my opinion um eighth one the
weed world I believe that it may be the
second wonder of the weed world because
we don't have seven wonders of the week
yeah yeah I only got one wonder of the
wheat world you thank you not but to me
yo yo yo uh your ranch reminds me of
like Disneyland or Disney World or
something that you know is another level
of entertainment but it's catered
towards the cannabis community and at
the same time is catered towards people
like you know who one of just four have
a resort to get away to have a great
time to relax themselves to get away and
just enjoy life like you building the
perfect paradise you built in heaven on
earth I was explaining to some people
when we had our first festival so many
different disenfranchised brothers
unable to see each other so year they
mean each other so years that you know
people may think of stoners a family
think outside it and had a chance all in
to intertwine with one another and that
was just a beautiful view to watch when
I was at the crane festival I think the
current festival represents people like
so yeah you definitely gonna have all
kinds of people there no matter what
they background is or what they make up
is like hey you represent love and I
like what the what the motto said what
did I say health it was what's the three
words that I said up there be faith be
kind be well exhausts right there be
safe be kind and be well that that just
sets the right spirit to know what you
coming into to know what you want to be
a part of I'm down with it might I can't
wait for you to ask me to perform at
what stocks on steroids
hell yeah dude I'm doing it man Snoop
October man put it on the couch
that's my birthday month me too yeah
let's just get how do those years feel
man through that ever you know what Mike
to survive that era I look back at it
because I know how deadly it was and how
life-threatening it was and I just thank
God that I had the precision to believe
in him to let him you know guide me and
put me on the path that I needed to be
on because I could have been reckless
and I could have been young and foolish
at one point in time I was but I chose
to believe in the fact that I'm gonna
let God leave me and I'm gonna follow
his direction as opposed to me trying to
lead cuz I'm bad at leading so once I
started letting him take controlling me
and lead me certain things started to
happen and and and things would you know
show me better vision on how I needed to
move and how needed to react to things
and I'm still here because that's the
that's the plan I've been going with and
I think that's a tribute to Who I am
while keeping God and everything I do
hmm yeah I believe that as well
that's amazing as well i tribute with my
grandmother and my mother and you know
the people in my life who you know put
this on me at an early age to give me
understanding and and have me aware and
to know that there's a difference
between good and bad right and wrong and
there's a purpose of why we do what we
do and once I understood that purpose I
try to practice that by being a better
person and just trying to be a better me
and being a reflection of what I'm
supposed to be and it just becomes a
part of me now it was just every day I
wake up to it it's not a routine that's
not an act it's just me being me and
I've learned to love more than hate and
that's the overall thing of it all just
to try to learn to love more because
it's easy to hate but it's hard to love
mm-hmm yeah I never really um my life
and I really believed in God
my life I have to learn to believe in
God late in life right God was always a
game playing the game gets thought I won
yes it's just the world I came from
everything was a game everything was
about the means of getting something was
nothing was real you know and doing the
tote you know really took me to another
expectation of God you know my whole
experience about God has always been
with someone told you with God would and
the book told you that God was always
somebody uh third party yeah so a third
party there's always somebody debating
somebody maybe a Muslim or he wants to
debate the Bible or somebody wants to
debate the UM the Quran the Quran
whatever there's always conflict in the
religion religion is conflict right
hatefulness and fight something they
know and something love among themselves
and then you only get love from religion
unless you follow our religion you
receive our love right okay right and
it's just so up until this day that's
what it's been right speak on okayed up
until this day that's what it's been
like owning and so I did this told that
the day yesterday matter of fact and you
know explain what the totus to some
people don't understand what it is yeah
cuz it's not like you told on somebody
I'm like I hope you ain't oh no nobody
my Shelby to explain it Dean the toad
it's a it's a mystical creature from the
Sonoran Desert at hibernates for ten
months of the year and and it comes out
during the raining during the monsoons
and they get this toad and they milk it
for lack of a better term of its venom
and its venom contains this molecule
called five Meo DMT and so when you take
five Meo DMT you vaporize it it
basically takes you through your life
and shows you your traumas and releases
you from it and you have to surrender
and it releases you from your pain so
that's that's a little bit about what
the toad is
she's crazy there's no sound yeah not
only I never spoken su over dick right
no only way I'll smoke that [ __ ] like
dog you know you're gonna die in about
four hours cup all right I could call
Mike up you like get that okay I want to
experience it hit that [ __ ]
photons and I'll like cut that
[ __ ] tall was amazing yeah we
inside to mike tyson podcast what's your
boy snoop d-o-double-g taking over this
[ __ ] leaning maintaining banging
and swing it you understand what I'm
saying so break it on water cuz we stand
real purified with Bishop magic one he's
not here I feel like I'm in here with
Bishop magic wand he should go to church
with a shoulder Mike I'm a cowgirl
I'm you have to get him on the set go
get him oh yes that's my experience
shifting Todai I got uh what's that word
again sentence integrated integration I
like that wow dude psychological was
integration okay hey Bishop got him on
there he was only I heard them so we can
watch em I love that well you add
churchy a green screen behind oh you
look beautiful baby how you doing man
how you doing my podcast when you gonna
come see us man you in LA I'm not doing
anything money I made with Snoop on a
podcast we talking [ __ ] where we at with
El Segundo Segundo we're in El Segundo
brother we got to get you on the podcast
you got your women with you that's live
Jack with you I'm with the champ
well what Mike Tyson amount respond Oh
ain't it man oh you and that thing oh
you play put that light back girl that's
like in Chicago remember that in Chicago
you Alyssa Carlo what that was he was in
Chicago with that car back in the day
babe you know let us look at how this is
beautiful dude no look he got my god
it's on the front end of it - it's a
church on the license plate [ __ ] man
you're gonna pick up one right now
yeah put on the back seat sure she don't
desire to ride in the front put in the
back I love to see you know those cars
don't have no character it cost a
million bucks but they don't have no
character baby I would love to do that
I'm gonna come by and see you at the
honeycomb what time you gonna be there
[Music]
well looking good looking good you got
there fire cannabis we got meat your
love it's so crazy but you guys can call
up anybody yeah my house you got
pictures with Donald Trump and
everything oh please believe it when I
tell you this oh oh wow we're doing the
eSports that's the [ __ ] yeah that
virtual [ __ ] yeah
when that's the [ __ ] dude mics in at all
brother he gotta be yeah because he's
Tyson and his brand exceeds the boxing
ring it needs to be everywhere needs to
be in every facet and everything moving
because he was culture
he was culture shocking when Mike was
the man he set the trend well how to
look how to wield jury and now he's
doing it again
that's what I'm saying so like it only
makes sense for him to to prosper
business-wise I believe in the beginning
when he was doing it it wasn't a
business move it's just he was just
naturally doing it yeah cuz that was the
move and probably a lot of people
prospered off of him other than him now
it's about him prospering off of him and
make sure his family and his legacy can
continue on so his kids and grandkids
can continue to have it like you know
regular people do it that are legends
they make sure that the legacy continues
to roll on and on and on no doubt yes
that's so awesome man well you've got
you've got a lot going on in cannabis I
try to yeah I try to do my part you have
awesome comments got a lot brother I
mean you're and you're in it we do a
little you know we like to let our
actually speak you know send loud in our
words but we kind of invested into the
cannabis industry some things I can't
speak on some things I can't speak on
but you know what that being said you
know I plan on doing my part you know
because I felt like I've contributed a
lot to the cannabis industry before I
was able to become legal so I felt like
I'm gonna get my issue when it finally
becomes legal and in a business manner
you know not in a you know ignant manner
but a business matter because I feel
like business-wise I was doing this when
it wasn't cool yeah not it is cool to do
it you might as well let me go ahead and
be the man the myth the legend because
I'm the one that's most connected Mike
is that anybody I gotta ask you a
question is anybody that you want to
smoke with that you never smoked with
cuz my dream was to smoke with Willie
Nelson and I did I smoked with Willie
Nelson he made me quit oh that
[ __ ] made me quit he was look
well we stood in a table like this
playing dominoes me and him he was the
money and I was on money we had a joint
Blount
vape a bong and
Wow and it was just me and him so we
just playing dominoes while we was
passing it back and forth and it got to
a certain point was like he was kicking
my ass and dominoes and I was getting
too [ __ ] high I was like man Willy we
need to get something eat guess what we
was in Amsterdam and it was for 2003 man
and we was in the cheap-ass hotel you
wouldn't believe we was in a hotel that
was so small but we didn't give a [ __ ]
it was about us it wasn't about having a
five-star hotel losing like the motel 6
some [ __ ] where it was like real low
budget and we ended up going to Kentucky
Fried Chicken it was just it was the
greatest experience of my life
wow man my experience check this out I'm
with Snoop I'm waiting outside of
Phoenix to the club he's an hour and a
half late he's on the bus either I would
have left it there on the buses he come
to the show he gets off the bus he sees
me and grabs you go back on a bus but
not a two-hour we came outside it was
jam-packed we couldn't even get in
that's the young snoop man I don't give
a [ __ ] man I'm sorry for making my fans
wait but y'all know I was happy to see
Chet I said hey that's one thing about
me I'm a big-ass kid man when I when I
see people that I love even to this day
I'm I'm infatuated with certain people
and I love their crafts or whatever
they're great at I love to give him a
hug and tell him I great deal and I want
to become their friend and that's just
that's just me I don't know why but
that's just who I am and that's why I'm
hey do you feel that that you keeps you
in tune with them what's going on I
think it does because it keeps me you
know knowing what's relevant and then
still being able to mix and match and be
able to be in the presence of those that
are great and to recognize that they're
great and to give them that credit for
being great hmm that's awesome Nipsey
though man he was a great brother great
brother great brother he had to spirit a
lot of people say that his beer was so
sick
the mines you know we looked alike we
are swag was similar yeah but he just to
me he was like Snoop Dogg with no flaws
like to me without the mess you know I'm
saying cuz I had a lot of mess in the
beginning of my career I believe he was
like going to do things that no one
could even imagine look at the love that
he's getting over point amount of love
that he's getting showing you that he
was inspiring and he was he was
something different than a regular man
yeah he was awesome and I remember
hearing like a mixtape when I was still
in the league
Wow years ago like ten years ago right I
was [ __ ] he'd been hustlin yeah he used
to sell tapes you know hand in hand like
go to you
door-to-door to your car on the corner
show up to the concert
he was even at a couple of my concerts
back in the days and I just found this
out that he was selling tapes outside of
my concert when I didn't even know him
so I'm like damn I that makes me respect
him that much more that he wasn't even
trying to get in the concert yeah I
don't want to get in there I'm just out
here trying to push these CDs yeah for
those that come out which had a hot
sauce hustlers mentality to want to go
get it as opposed to being next to it I
want to go get it
yeah that's like a door-to-door salesman
mentality yeah you know that's been lost
because there's so many overnight
superstars in social media you can make
your own video and become a star based
off of any kind of ridiculous song or
statement or whatever you do this man
hustled the original way the hardcore
way though the from the ground up you
know I'm saying the roots way of you
know doing it in the community for the
community and then he built things in
the community and he bought in the
community then he employed the community
that's the ghetto superstar right yeah
moment you think I was the reason that
he exploded and expanded to all
knowledge man such a short time his
spirit there's love you only get love
when you give love you know the spirit
that he was people are starting in life
even people I didn't know him they
researching and they're studying it like
menace this man was a loving beautiful
spirit man and then the the way his
death
because this death was on tape so people
seen it it doesn't match his spirit like
that doesn't go with his spirit you
don't see someone who's that
charismatic so prolific so beautiful so
about the community you're taken out
like that in the community so it's it
takes you back to Malcolm X it takes you
back to Martin Luther King Huey P Newton
takes you back to the leaders of the
black community that were assassinated
but their spirit of love trumped the
assassination and they spirit and their
legacy lived on forever I feel like I'm
on this trance of the toad right now
so keep coming back see that's why I
don't want to [ __ ] with you can see I
ain't telling the [ __ ] the truth that
[ __ ] don't just leave like this
[ __ ] right here just gonna leave in a
minute when I stop and get something eat
it's gonna be like our [ __ ] you won't
shoot at toast I like that [ __ ]
just hangs around and be like get back
in toad mode but I don't wanna get in
told Moe Amen I'm trying to be serious
right now I don't give a [ __ ] getting
Tomo but you're kind of already in toad
mode story be told I'm loving to be some
completely different if I do that thing
man yeah I know what am i I mean I don't
know when I'm gonna die I'm gonna holla
at y'all when I'm gonna need it yeah
exactly it calls to you man
for real when I want to get that
closeness some blue screen people come
next day they okay are you alright I'm
just doing some toad yeah I know they
think I have fancies at my house you
know the game is to be sold not to be
told absolutely because you know the
real see the real reality of it is that
um those those old goggles letting you
guys that still alive you know it's just
people don't pray too
why well I say that my you're right
you're right you're so right to blame
acknowledge to them they don't know they
exist they're still alive right
that's heavy that you said that because
our because I always want to know gods
are there limit or do they continue to
reproduce listen right this is the deal
our whole existence has been about
serving you know true even they come
from arrogant people the most the
biggest service the biggest service just
because there's there we can't once it's
the most arrogant mm-hmm and they have
been made believers beaten in submission
and we didn't not even worthy of being
oh [ __ ] that's right
yeah yeah there's many gods I think both
the dark and the light right you know
both sides
yeah cuz everything in the universe has
a yin and yang right it has to be yeah
rock was a good to do' yeah for sure
there's not necessarily that it's just
dark wise how you use them yeah it's so
true that is so true it's the truth man
Snoop are you doing any more acting I
just dropped a movie with Matthew
McConaughey called Beach but that's
right yes I'm telling you guys right yes
yeah beach bum it's in theaters right
now make sure y'all go check it out it's
a STONER flake love it you know saying
this in this world it's in his name you
put chickens on them really out of
business dude
oh not in my dogs you know they'd never
be out of business they actually
capitalized it right now actually Tommy
Chong was pushing bones for a long time
that's what they took him to jail for he
wasn't selling weed he was selling bongs
and they took me to jail for it but uh
you know Cheech and Chong shout-out to
them because they was like the first
pioneers of this [ __ ]
but his smoking [ __ ] this duo
combination two million oh so he'd laugh
at ya
smoke yeah man nice dreams yeah nice
thing they got the I got corn asylum and
stuff that ball started itching when a
spherical [ __ ] that was funny as [ __ ]
yeah it was funny as [ __ ] no job and
then she started doing kid [ __ ] after
why as a yeah you see that yeah he'd be
doing like rated G [ __ ] like that
playing like the dad the teacher so that
means everybody can change Trudy Trudy
absolutely man I think we all have the
capacity to change what you saying that
some people will never change yes that's
true that's based off of who you are but
right I mean I feel they have to be felt
that they need to change like Snoop I
don't know how you feel but me as a
Libra I feel my whole life is about
balance always always say that I say
that even when it comes to like
misunderstandings in the industry
they always call me like to be the one
to settle the differences well I know
about John the guy that they call him
like if his two rappers beefing at the
end of the day uncle snook won't get a
call from both after birth so Austin and
I'll put the leverage on you was wrong
when you was wrong let's get right you
know I'm never gonna say that you know
I'm saying so that way it always gets
resolved and it's like that's just been
my rule for like the past 15 years like
they call me uncle snoop can you believe
I know I didn't know that's why they
called you that's that doesn't it make
sense now
it totally does if there's a who last
uncle that you can go to you help you
with [ __ ] to do to help you navigate and
obedient when things ain't right it's
yeah uncle slow I've been the same guy
in my life for real right yes absolutely
man on the Commission yeah absolutely
it's confirmation to this labor thing
why is our sign why is our sign based on
a scale right I know
it's just that's our life we're like our
lives are that embodiment of that they
don't even bother you to balance it out
now no like you got so used to it now
yeah yes it's just your thing yeah they
late they want me to be mad at certain
people or like if somebody do me wrong
when you're like I still get
an opportunity or give them another shot
they play man I wouldn't I don't know
how you do a dog you'd be always right
yeah I'm pretty sure they tell you that
all that mimic enemies your friend amen
you kill him with love to thank you
kindness yeah kill him with kindness man
I have seen you know cuz I man there was
a time in my football playing days where
I was a [ __ ] psychopath had so much
anger and rage in me man and I've been
the guy to escalate things but my mate
my nature is in just coming back with
love you know if someone has a an issue
with me or something I did or with my
wife she says something to me I go okay
you know how can I make this better
true you know not how can I escalate it
what can I take responsibility for and
just surrender to right now where I was
wrong you know and it's like [ __ ] man
that and you end it with a smile and a
hug and I love you and then you know
things are good other than that man it's
like [ __ ] dude life is too short to be
pissed off Joe it hurts I got a question
for you yeah now you play football and a
lot of my friends cuz I have a football
league friends my son a lot of people
play football a lot of them have
sustained certain injuries and the top
concussion he had a CTE thing yeah do
you feel that this is helping you
contend with your CTE better than most
players who played in league Snoop I
love you do I love you for asking that
you know because that's how I got here
wow I came out of the league and I
started writing and speaking about how
cannabis see I believe cannabis not only
as an alternative to the opiates and the
pills and all that [ __ ] but cannabis
kept my mind together through all the
brain injuries you know and then I find
out our federal government has a patent
on cannabinoids as neuroprotective sand
antioxidants Allah patents six million
six hundred and thirty
didn't find another needy and I believe
that because I smoked throughout my
career snoop I would come home every day
driving home blasting your music and I
was smoking a joint on my phone felt
good about it
dude it was ideal body your body got
back intact why it was the only thing
that would get me ready for that grind
again I gotta see the house smoking is
in the news if I'm driving me in a [ __ ]
and I was just in the zone in those days
man
cuz I'm noticing now like it's becoming
more conversation now yeah there's a lot
of guys that left a league or saying
[ __ ] it I smoked when I was in there I
couldn't have said it when I was there
but I'm saying it now yeah y'all
[ __ ] gave me pills and [ __ ]
me up
y'all send me two neurologists that [ __ ]
me up when I got rid of all of that [ __ ]
and just start going home smoking when I
could when that time period when y'all
stop testing yeah when I was smoking and
getting right oh I was right right yeah
it's a lot of y'all that's coming to the
table now saying look here man trying to
speak for both us in the league to try
to help them now now exact because your
voice matters because first of all if I
had a successful career and I'm don't
have any brain damage and I'm still able
to sustain and communicate and
articulate that's what I want for these
young player up some I don't want them
coming out the league frustrated Mac
suicidal get into domestic spice because
that's what the [ __ ] is about exactly
when you see a player get into a fight
an altercation or something with his
woman let me give the synopsis of it all
because a lot of people don't understand
this tell them you got a football player
that's been coached his whole life and
his coach been telling shut up do this
you ain't [ __ ] get better you got a ride
blah blah and you can never say nothing
to the coach but no sir yes sir no sir
yes sir now you take this grown man
who's been told that his whole life now
he has a companion at home who's his
wife his girlfriend he's used to hearing
the coach cuss him out all day all day
then he goes home and now the girl wants
to cuss him out oh now she wants to
argue so now his capacity for her is not
for the coach I'm not gonna say no sir
yes so to her I'm liable to beat her ass
or put hands on or do something
aggressive because I can't control yes
this [ __ ] up top
and I've been controlling on the
football field my whole life and now I'm
coming home to my girl arguing with me
she just pushed one button that may
cause me to kill her or kill myself or
do something detrimental that I'm gonna
lose my contract and lose my mind and
lose my life am i lying
you are dead on them that's exactly
right you know that's why we have all
this [ __ ] man you're you're programmed
to run on adrenalin and cortisol in the
fight-or-flight mode and if you don't
have anything to come home most guys
they're taking pills they're drinking
alcohol right which exacerbates all that
[ __ ] man
when if you just allowed guys to use
this to come home don't forget cocaine
cocaine if you allowed guys to come home
and smoke a little weed decompress I get
you out of that fight-or-flight mode
while then it's invaluable like you said
you're not gonna have these young guys
aren't gonna have to leave the league in
shambles that's what's happening to him
I known nobody nobody's going underneath
the store they just seeing all this
domestic fighting and all this but they
not knowing that this guy is programmed
to get cussed out and talk bad to by his
coaches his whole life and then he comes
home and now his girlfriend wants to
talk to him like that
so true ma'am like that's a fine line
right to you yeah and if you don't know
you don't know and the NFL wants to hide
it they want to hide it they want to
sweep it under the rug and they want to
[ __ ] blame these kids these guys know
and kick him out the door
know help him drive who helped him if
you assisted him he would have a tone
down that's why most rappers don't have
that domestic dispute because we if we
get into argument with our girl we
jumping in the car smoking are we riding
off-road and we own to the next you get
what I'm saying is it's a difference
it's a scenario because we don't have
those rules and regulations we don't
have a commissioner we don't have drug
tests we don't have none of that we have
whatever we want and we dictate what we
did tell you and I feel like that's
what's missing from the NFL yeah no
doubt man thank you bro come on I'm
having an awesome day here they're so
awesome like
legend in the house ma'am hey shout out
to the NHL uh MLB cuz your mates yelling
the MLB don't test that's right oh hell
no I smoked with a lot of baseball
players and hockey guys right during
this season after the season I mean it's
a beautiful thing hockey is the [ __ ] so
they bring - don't tell me knock and
this is a charity game so gonna sit and
I'm gonna lobby to meet the guy and so
I'm gonna lobby the guys are but neck
everybody right so no but but the level
the woman that's a report it's right in
the center of [ __ ] they're all around
her and she's talking to him talking to
honey
drinking champagne as you know they get
to fight Mike and the referee just leave
them alone and no like get like a brawl
like it to somebody fall out yeah that's
interesting you know about the cultures
of sports right because football players
are savages but they're they've been so
beaten down right that you don't have
the luxury of being an individual that's
why I always loved Randy Moss man yeah
cuz he he was him yeah at all times at
all times and I always loved that about
Randy and you know well you know he was
raised off that Snoop Dog music so oh
hell yeah it should be bad today of
course ma'am that means a horse and you
are the Godfather then from a war yeah
for real like if I'm in war like a
soccer with investigators now good long
and mean that even they fight they cut
the head off of it and they play faculty
kicking it around are you saying that's
how soccer is invented I don't [ __ ]
believe you Mike you guys [ __ ] they
total we're doing so I'm not gonna move
that [ __ ] [ __ ] all that
at old man [ __ ] all that [ __ ] somebody
cutting the head off then it started
soccer started being so how they create
basketball someone [ __ ] walking down
alleys like me [ __ ] all that now I'm
gonna Madoff mr. Nate mr. makes me sick
this is what getting highs all the
research right give me some research
Mike give my game right Brazilian soccer
fan you can tell you right after he stay
[Laughter]
I'm gonna say how was soccer in Venice
yes England invented a game of running
and kicking a ball in the mid 19th
century although the Chinese claim to
have played a version centuries earlier
they called it football not because the
ball is played with feet but because the
game is played on foot rather than a
horseback but I need to know how it was
created was that oh it's cuz I see a
rock right there with him uh [ __ ]
monkey like to begin the time he heard
his please kick that [ __ ] he was
like man that [ __ ] hurt we gotta
get some softening that goddamn rock to
kick and I got no shoes [ __ ] name a
shoe [ __ ] he's trying to kick us a rock
like a soccer ball with no shoes so that
didn't work then they got over here like
to England people try to create some
[ __ ] what country was the the Japan they
said no Chinese go to China go to China
own I want to know the beginner that
[ __ ] might come out to [ __ ] before the
present like Genghis Khan my gang is
calling for invented Jeremy Jeremy
warfare sure yeah don't dead rotting
bodies over the wall are you saying yeah
Wow
Snoop we're trying to do I need that
light isn't the guy's a [ __ ]
they come up with all kind of [ __ ] you
need to be a game food will be back but
whatever Mike says for 500 well
like to have a little history show
history was like okay I kind of believe
it but that tokeep overwhelming my fault
can anybody verify that soccer was
created by somebody getting a haircut
off yeah put that yeah soccer invented
right see I need to have what's the
[ __ ] named Alexis with no sirree when
I'm theory before one year the [ __ ]
that did serious was it miss Terry
before in real life yeah very nice lady
dude look legend has it that the first
time this celebratory sport was played
in Britain was after the defeat of a
Danish Prince after decapitating the
Prince and true barbarian fashion they
decided to kick around his head no word
on who had to clean up after him
yeah oh [ __ ] see Mike is mike is tapped
in mister story he's very historic he's
very historic neuters tapped I liked it
I liked it that's insane
he tapped in yeah but you're a big
football fan I love football and soccer
yeah I've been in these countries before
what I'm actually not give me to come
back I'm players you know Ronaldo
barnardine oh yeah a drug ba yeah yeah
Wayne Rooney David I'm at Wayne Rooney I
met David Pele um I met Haley yeah
mythos Pele Donna huh how's Payless I'm
a failure
it's the distinguished that's big it's a
bad Hey ladies no man that's Pele man
knock it off cool confident paint like
you just gone into the World Cup
unless you I want to go work up I'd be
fun I went there you did not went after
they went oh don't play the [ __ ]
got one name you know that is [ __ ]
yeah hey hey lag when I last Russia with
Pele right like give the horse name paid
last name lake football plays a legend
man that's how I should walk in the
party yeah [ __ ]
first name pay last name way I believe
it things no one ever seen before he did
he did the helicopter kick a football
kick yeah then he was he probably was
faster nearby - that's one in the
nineteen sixties you know [ __ ]
but he probably the only black dude out
there was fast as a [ __ ] - he
was doing tricks with the ball and um
saying his IQ out there was was hella
but he know how to pass the ball and get
other people involved he's a team player
he wasn't selfish you know I'm saying
that's what made him great that he could
have just did it all by yourself but he
was involved in everybody else like I
like players like that Dez that's team
orientated you good enough to be bad by
yourself but you know the team makes me
better when we all look good like that
have you guys seen that movie victory
this Sly Stallone
Pele's in it yeah yeah yeah and they're
in a concentration camp yeah or it's
like a POWs or war camp
yeah it's called victory you tell
victory and Pele's in it and they go
they form a team to play the Nazis in
Paris to play against Hitler to get and
then they escape at the end cuz they
whip their ass
Pele's in it that's dopest oh that's
[ __ ] dope just that idea so movie
it's like it's the soccer version of
Longest Yard oh that was the [ __ ] that
Burt Reynolds yeah
that [ __ ] was hard yeah you know
that move ready to clothesline
yeah when I was playing quarterback in
1981
[ __ ] clothesline me like that in
a game and the ref didn't call nothing
that was real football boo my way right
into that let me just flip BAM everybody
crowded like oh every football player
has that moment not for real yeah I felt
good with my son was nothing good you
know what I never played high school
football so when he did high school
football that was like my dream come
true any excelled he won a national
championship they played big games on
ESPN he got recruited he signed a
scholarship to UCLA like all that [ __ ]
that I wanted to do he did and it was
like it was fun watching it is so
awesome beautiful yeah right that's that
shows that you've done something as a
kid that that you could be proud of make
your parents proud that you have
universities interested in paying for
you to go to school they get off of your
ability and you working at something
yeah like that that was the ultimate for
me because I know in my neighborhood a
lot of guys went to the NFL went to
college so I know what it took for them
to make it so to see my son not use my
celebrity and not use me but all him you
know what I'm saying like that was like
oh that's a lot yeah
congratulations man thank you stoked as
hell thank you
did you like go with him to any any of
the trips to see schools nah the coaches
came to him okay he went to a couple of
pitches that I was like I going they'll
shoot all they did was to do he got game
they put all of yours on in the course
you know I didn't he I like this school
yeah yeah how many women did they put on
you oh two of them I think I like to
school there he must have put some Isis
panic girls on your ass yeah that the
routine and then when he got back home
it's paradise when we got back home he
started like breaking down his choices
and I'm like why you don't like that
school no more they tried to use me it
sorry
no girls over you star and they got told
you that they gonna try to do then he
started to like Jim Moore Jim Moore was
a hell of a coach like yeah the things
he said like the family vibe and just a
gym or just felt like our father like
like I could pass my son over
to him that's all so you get him saying
like that's a decision that you got to
make when you at that point like I'm
giving my son there's somebody to be his
father for the next four years
yeah and he just felt like he can handle
it yeah I met Jim he when he was
coaching the Seahawks cuz I was going
into the draft at the combine I thought
he was a good dude he is is a great guy
yeah great man I love him a lot that's
awesome man
well he got fired right yeah this woman
yeah of course
what is fine he turned the city around
actually he'd be that's it I know so
they they was wrong for that they'll pay
because chips not gonna do it that fast
pace [ __ ] as office is not gonna
work yeah cuz the kids don't go there
you gotta have the right kids to go to
the program to run that type of [ __ ]
yeah and you're not getting them st not
getting them you not getting their going
to the SCC in the ACC yeah that's just
what's happening right now you guys
aren't winning you guys programs don't
look right
kids are smart they they know I want to
be on TV I want to be in big games and I
want an opportunity to try to go to the
NFL yeah yeah no doubt
where they going Alabama Clemson Georgia
Florida State Ohio State yeah anything
that's bigger and better than what we
looking like right now yeah I know man
back when I was at Arizona SC was in
their prime Lindale white-nose yeah
Reggie and [ __ ] was just crazy it was
like a pro team who read you a bush but
see that's because Pete Carroll had a
systematic team that was grounded in
making sure first of all nothing out of
Southern California leaves here we get
all of that first yeah second we're
gonna go to Texas and grab a few we're
gonna go to Florida grab a few we're
gonna go to all the areas that you don't
think we can go to and we're gonna get a
couple of them guys that come
mix-and-match what else is good Pete
Carroll had a nice system in place to
where kids wanted to play for him and
they wanted to play for his coaches not
just him but his staff look who was on
his staff he had kid Finch our keys in
the end
oh gee Ronnie had a bunch of guys that
ended or they ended up going and having
great coach man please yeah yeah
were you in SC fan growing up died or
Charles white Marcus Allen Rickey Bell
you know saying I go back
war number 12 when I played football cuz
I love Charles White so much though I
played quarterback for like five years
and then I got switched to Y receiver
because it was too much [ __ ] going on
you gotta learn too much to be a
quarterback I'm like damn I'm just I'm
on the ball right and left to read and
coverage a whole [ __ ] all that I'm going
to wire saver
that's too much yeah it's too much
information yeah
Mike G play football never played sports
to fight Wow well that's a good sport
fighting a [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna go get my cousin Mike to
beat us that's the original you know I
was younger than him oh just a little mo
[ __ ] already
yeah he'll stoop how's it been
partnering up with Martha Stewart on
some stuff doesn't that look awesome
together it's dope you're like almost
like a man what do you call that stuff
again I forgot like um infomercial guy
white guy you know what our relationship
is so dope because it's a mutual love
and respect and it's like I love being
around people that know more than me and
she knows more than me she's wiser than
me and she's smarter than me and you
know it's the information you know
magnet when I'm around her and we we get
a lot from each other like I give her a
little she give me a lot and this is
what love is about like just meeting
people and connecting Rose goes Bates
thank you
we're gonna eat it afterwards though cuz
I don't want a message interview up
right now I'd be smacking this [ __ ] all
in the interview not be yourself dude
mama that's why I'm gonna beat myself
and wait till we finish cuz I'm gonna
eat like a [ __ ] I don't want to
be talking when I'm eating what do you
guys check it out when we barged in uh
bars and bees flowers and trees and this
is what happens when you party with Mike
Tyson right housemates
post mates baby pod sponsor is that in
the way to shot you need to move that
they're looking up that's exciting
yeah
right Mike riposte nice thing I'm gonna
use that should even when I ain't up
here and just tell them I'm with Mike
yeah yeah I need to get a 415 yes
I put it on my tab post mates yes yes no
no you can't recognize my [ __ ] voice
is me yes like I was saying before you
rule II interrupted me I'd like to get
15 orders of baby back ribs yungang way
dude I don't know Mike I stay like I'm
posed to be in Timmy slim and trim what
else you got going now man what are your
projects are currently working on I'm
working on the album right now called I
want to thank me should be out
mmm late-may early-june putting together
a movie with it as well and just trying
to keep my foot in the game you know I
do Records when I want to not because I
have to yeah and I feel like it's
necessary for me to make some music
again because it's a period of time
where I feel like it's a void I always
make music when it's a void when it's
something like nothing like I do and or
is something that I need to say that's
not being said so that's what I'm doing
with this project right here
that's awesome who you'd like to work
with well it's only one artist I really
want to work with that's a date I've
been trying to reach out to her for a
minute you know I'd be awesome I'm
trying to make it happen I just want to
get in a room with a minute cuz I love
her voice our style our whole everything
and I just think we can make some real
you know extravagant definitely though
I'd even wear my hair in a ponytail that
day just fire I'll slick it back with
jail like how you feel hi yeah feel good
chilled chilled out with the tote I'm
good a minute old game special shout out
to all the people out there that they've
been supporting - Mike Tyson podcast
support my main man yeah appreciate the
love it's what we do man I'm special
guest on the show but
very honored to be a part of a show
that's so special
then it's brother here he's the man dude
thank you so much man
hey man thank you all for having me and
I do love the cup right here this is
something that y'all wanna write yes sir
I could tell because my father's don't
put cups in the middle and it's a prized
possession of something and it's full of
joint so what I'm gonna do is yours I
didn't do nothing to show him it's gonna
take a few Wigga later only damned want
to see Bishop in that oh one of those
and then i'ma go see my dynasty we love
you I know she gonna try to get one too
yeah don't make no sense for the media
just that they don't even make no sense
don't make no sense for them to be up
there that cup look so much better
without it's beautiful though it's
beautiful look at that cup you look good
oh yeah thanks brother help bishop I
love them man I love you too Mikey Mike
another grade up man charge it to the
game back to the game well thanks
everybody thanks for listening to this
episode of hot box and I'm Evan Britton
I'm Mike Tyson and I'm big smoke dope
and we're out of here please
[Music]